[Music]
have you ever been in love no one's ever
offered that anything to you before I
don't have to print it from what that
story that's written all over your face
[Music]
well grab breakfast I just met you do
you make time for one another in what
way do you have date night yeah would
you do this
this is love at its absolute best and
it's beautiful sometimes I can't bring a
baby into the world with man that I
don't love don't do it because you're
scared you must own your actions in life
[Music]
that's great
this isn't a sex injury I mean not a
weird one hey why are you still talking
wrong I don't know love is trust and you
broke it I don't love him
it's totally my dad you're gonna smell
you smell them
Oh your stay in New York she's staying
with us okay have you guys discussed
that we're discussing here right now
it's a live discussion I'm so glad
you've told me it explains so much
[Music]
surely there is someone out there
we'll take me for who I am the good
that's the shuffle story up
[Music]
sweet
[Music]
you